معنا من رفح مراسل الجزيره هشام زقوت هشام
قربنا اكثر من المشهد الميداني والانساني
في غزه هذا
الصباح المشهد الميداني هو عمليات قصف
اسرائيلي مستمره خاصه في خانيونس ربما
انخفضت حده القصف الاسرائيلي في مناطق
مختلفه من قطاع غزه لكن خانيونس مازالت
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي متواجده على
الارض متواجده في محيط مستشفى ناصر وفي
محيط مستشفى الامل وتقصف ما بين الفينه
والاخرى بال المدفعيه و بالمدفعيه منازل
المدنيين الفلسطينيين في تلك المناطق
بالاضافه الى ان هناك طائرات مسيره كواد
كابتر تحلق في سماء تلك المناطق وتطلق
النار على كل من يحاول التحرك الاخطر في
كل ذلك ان هذه المستشفيات ما زالت محاصره
وبالتالي لا تستطيع وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه ايصال المساعدات ايصال الغذاء
ايصال المياه الى هذه المستشفيات المحاصره
منذ اكثر من اسبوع وبالتالي هؤلاء المرضى
هؤلاء الاطباء والطاقم الطبي الذين
يتواجدون في تلك المستشفيات لا يستطيعون
الحصول على هذا الغذاء ولا على هذا الدواء
ولا على هذه المياه وهذا ما تحذر منه
وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه بان هؤلاء يواجهون
خطرا بالاضافه الى خطر القصف الاسرائيلي
المتواصل يواجهون خطر الجوع ويواجهون خطر
العطش من جراء نقص المستلزمات ونقص الغذاء
والمياه في هذه المستشفيات اضطروا ايضا
خاصه مستشفى الامل ومستشفى ناصر اضطروا
الى دفن الشهداء الذين يسقطون او حتى
يستطيعون وصول بعض الشهداء وصلوا الى هذه
المستشفيات اضطروا الى دفنهم في ساحات هذه
المستشفيات من جراء بسبب عدم قدره الطواقم
الطبيه او حتى الاسعافات على الوصول الى
المقابر من هذه الاماكن الدبابات
الاسرائيليه وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
انسحبت من بعض المناطق في خانيونس واعادت
التمركز والتموضع في مناطق اخرى لكن هذا
الانسحاب هو انسحاب جزئي لكنها ما زالت
ايضا تحاصر تلك المناطق تتواجد على الش
الشوارع الاساسيه والرئيسيه وتسيطر على
تلك الشوارع وتتحكم في تفاصيل المشهد
وتعتقل الرجال الذين يحاولون النزوح او
الخروج من خان يونس باتجاه مدينه رفح
للنزوح اليها ايضا قصفت الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه محيط مستشفى الاوروبي في
المناطق الشماليه لمدين في المناطق
الشرقيه لمدينه خانيونس وكان هناك عدد من
الاصابات جراء هذا الاستهداف نقلوا الى
هذا المستشفى وتم علاجهم في تلك المنطقه
ايه ايضا القصف الاسرائيلي مازال متواصل
في المناطق الوسطى منطقه شرق مخيم المغازي
شرق مخيم البريج المناطق الشماليه لمخيم
النصيرات ما زالت تتعرض الى قصف من
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه القصف ربما هدا في
شمال القطاع لكنه مازال مستمر ايضا في
مدينه غزه في شمال القطاع الجيش
الاسرائيلي اعاد الانسحاب او انسحب من
مناطق جديده واعاد التموضع في مناطق اخرى
وبالتالي حده القصف الاسرائيلي في تلك
المناطق التي انسحب منها الجيش الاسرائيلي
خاصه في منطقه بيت لاهيه الانسحاب كان
واضحا وهي المنطقه الاساسيه والرئيسيه
التي توغل منها الجيش الاسرائيلي الى
مدينه غزه والى المناطق في شمال القطاع
انسحب منها وبالتالي حده القصف الاسرائيلي
هدات نوعا ما في تلك المناطق لكن الجيش
الاسرائيلي مازال مستمر في عمليه التوغل
في مدينه غزه خاصه في مفترقات اساسيه
ورئيسيه في حيت ل الهواء مفترق الماليه
ومفترق انصار وهذه المفترقات اساسيه في
مدينه غزه في القاطع الغربي من المدينه ما
زال الجيش الاسرائيلي يواصل توغله وايضا
يواصل قصف تلك المناطق لكن ايضا في رفح
ربما حده القصف الاسرائيلي هي الاقل من
محافظات قطاع غزه باكملها لكن الاوضاع
الانسانيه في رفح صعبه للغايه نحن نشهد
احوال جويه سيئه امطار ورياح شديده خلال
ساعات المساء وصباح هذا اليوم وبالتالي كل
هذا يؤثر على النازحين الذين باتوا بشكل
كبير في العراء وجزء كبير منهم في خيام
مهترئه وخيام لا لا تليق بالحياه في
الانسانيه في كافه المحافظات في مدينه رفح
يتواجد مليون و300 ال نسمه هؤلاء جلهم
يعيشون في خيام اقتلعت بعض الخيام من جراء
الرياح الشديده وغرقت خيام اخرى ومن يجد
خيمه هو ربما محظوظ في ظل هذه الاحوال
الجويه السيئه خاصه ان جزء كبير من الناس
والسكان الذين نزحوا من مدينه خان يونس هم
في شوارع بدون ماوى في ظل احوال جويه
واوضاع معيشيه صعبه بدون توفر ادنى مقومات
الحياه شكرا لك هشام زقوت مراسل الجزيره
كنت معنا من رفح جنوب قطاع غزه